con este vídeo líder de la banda 400
abuso amenazó a las autoridades
haitianas de matar a los 17 misioneros
estadounidenses secuestrados el pasado
16 de octubre
juro por el trueno que si no consigo lo
que pido les meteré una bala en la
cabeza de estos americanos
amenaza que se haría realidad de no
recibir los 17 millones de dólares que
está pidiendo por su liberación esta
situación ha generado un caos en puerto
príncipe en donde el panorama se reduce
a barricadas humo y llantas en llamas
los manifestantes haitianos rechazan las
actividades criminales de la pandilla
400 magos aparentemente responsable de
los más recientes casos de inseguridad y
escasez de combustible en la región
suben maletas al envía una advertencia
al gobierno para que no entre en la
lógica de negociar con estos bandidos
que hacen la ley del país según las
naciones unidas tan sólo entre enero y
agosto de este año se reportaron 320
secuestros en puerto príncipe una ciudad
en donde el 40% de su territorio está
dominado por las pandillas la casa
blanca insiste en que hará todo lo
posible para facilitar la liberación
working estamos trabajando de manera
cercana con el fbi quien lidera en este
tipo de eventos en constante
comunicación con la policía nacional
haitiana la iglesia a la que pertenecen
los misioneros así como el gobierno de
haití desde el asesinato del presidente
joven el mois el pasado 7 de julio la
crisis sociopolítica y económica de
haití se ha deteriorado permitiendo el
aumento de secuestros robos violaciones
y ataques armados